This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the spring of 2004, journalist Mark Gleason sat in the front row of a small conference room in Switzerland for a big announcement. There was a dramatic buildup, there was a lot of tension, everyone was on edge. The winning bid to host the 2010 FIFA World Cup was about to be revealed, and South Africa was among the leading contenders.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2004年春天，记者马克·格里森坐在瑞士一个小会议室的前排，等待着一个重大公告。现场气氛紧张，充满戏剧性的铺垫，每个人都如坐针毡。2010年国际足联世界杯的主办权即将揭晓，南非是主要竞争者之一。
I mean, they had all the top guns go to Zurich for that particular announcement. Mandela was there, Bishop Tutu was there, the former president of Clack was there. South Africa wanted to be the first African nation to host the World Cup. They also wanted the tournament to be the start of a new chapter. During apartheid, the country was banned from the international sporting community. Now they were on the precipice of hosting soccer's biggest event. South Africans gathered in the streets of Johannesburg,
我的意思是，他们派出了所有重量级人物前往苏黎世参加那次公告。曼德拉去了，图图大主教去了，克拉克前总统也去了。南非希望成为第一个举办世界杯的非洲国家。他们也希望这届赛事能开启新的篇章。在种族隔离时期，南非被国际体育界禁赛。现在，他们正处于举办足球界最大盛事的边缘。南非人聚集在约翰内斯堡的街头，
Cape Town, and Durban to await FIFA's decision. I discovered with you, the 2010 FIFA World Cup will be organized in South Africa. You know, South Africa had come full circle in the sense of it's horrible past and how it had moved on from being a pariah state and was now, you know, hosting the biggest event in world sport and very much part of the international family. The celebrations that erupted that day in Zurich were full of cheers and whistles, but also one notorious sound that came to define South Africa's World Cup. The sound of the Vuvuzella. Back in 2004, nobody really talked about Vuvuzella's.
开普敦和德班等待着国际足联的决定。我向你们宣布，2010年国际足联世界杯将在南非举办。你知道，南非在某种意义上已经走出了可怕的过去，不再是一个被排斥的国家，现在它正在举办世界体育界最大的盛事，并真正成为了国际大家庭的一员。那天在苏黎世爆发的庆祝活动充满了欢呼和哨声，但也伴随着一种后来定义了南非世界杯的臭名昭著的声音。呜呜祖拉的声音。早在2004年，还没人真正谈论过呜呜祖拉。
Even people in the soccer world didn't know what they were. Reporter James Parkinson. But six years later, by the time the first game of the tournament was underway, the Vuvuzella was the hottest word in sports. The 2010 FIFA World Cup is ready for kickoff into the sound of 18,000 Vuvuzellas. The fun of a fun of… The Vuvuzella is a two-foot long injection molded plastic horn. It plays only one note, a B-flat, and it gradually became a regular feature of South African
即使是足球界的人也不知道那是什么。记者詹姆斯·帕金森。但六年后的今天，当锦标赛的第一场比赛开始时，呜呜祖拉成了体育界最热门的词汇。2010年国际足联世界杯准备开球，伴随着18000支呜呜祖拉的声音。呜呜祖拉是一种两英尺长的注塑塑料喇叭。它只能吹出一个音符，降B调，它逐渐成为南非足球的常规特色。
Soccer. But prior to the 2010 World Cup, the rest of the world had never heard anything quite like it. And a lot of people hiked it. It's been likened to a giant swarm of angry hornets or a herd of destroyed elephants. So loud, the stating with the booze, zealous. It's ridiculous, it's not noisy, there's nothing irritating about it. For fans watching abroad, the constant drone of a vuvuzella wasn't what the beautiful game typically sounds like.
但在2010年世界杯之前，世界其他地方从未听过类似的声音。很多人讨厌它。它被比作一群愤怒的大黄蜂或一群受惊的象群。声音太大了，呜呜祖拉的嗡嗡声。这太荒谬了，这不叫吵闹，这没什么令人恼火的。对于在国外观看比赛的球迷来说，呜呜祖拉持续不断的嗡嗡声并不是这项美丽运动通常听起来的样子。
European soccer games, or football games, are often characterized by songs and chants bellowed by the supporters. But the harm of 80,000 vizillas drowned out that type of crowd noise. The sound caused actual headaches for television broadcasters. French network TF1 opted to change their commentators' microphones for a kind that would eject more background noise. Other networks chose to use special audio filters to try and eliminate the vivicella from their sound mix altogether. The controversy surrounding the vivicella was hard to ignore.
欧洲足球比赛通常以支持者高唱的歌曲和口号为特征。但8万支呜呜祖拉的嗡嗡声淹没了那种人群的噪音。这种声音让电视转播商感到头疼。法国TF1电视台选择更换评论员的麦克风，以过滤掉更多的背景噪音。其他网络则选择使用特殊的音频过滤器，试图将呜呜祖拉的声音从混音中彻底消除。围绕呜呜祖拉的争议让人难以忽视。
It drew attention away from the players on the field and placed the focus on the crowd in the stadiums. It also sparked a debate about the history of the vivicella and its true origins. For critics, the vivicella was a relatively new mass-produced noise maker, but for supporters, they tended to think of the vivicella as an instrument, a loud, attention-graping sound that grew out of South Africa's rich football
它将注意力从场上的球员身上转移到了看台上的观众身上。它还引发了一场关于呜呜祖拉历史及其真正起源的辩论。对于批评者来说，呜呜祖拉是一种相对较新的大规模生产的噪音制造器，但对于支持者来说，他们倾向于将呜呜祖拉视为一种乐器，一种源于南非丰富足球传统的响亮、引人注目的声音。
in tradition. In 1862, there's already documented matches that took place in Cape Town in Port Elizabeth. That's South African football, historian, Peter Allegi. And that is a year before the Football Association was even founded in England and before the first rules of the Association football were codified. Originally the sport was introduced by British colonizers, seeking to impose their beliefs and values on the locals, but quickly South Africans embraced football and made it their own.
1862年，开普敦和伊丽莎白港就已经有记录在案的比赛了。南非足球历史学家彼得·阿莱吉说。那甚至是在英格兰足球协会成立之前，也是足球协会的第一条规则被编纂之前。最初，这项运动是由英国殖民者引入的，他们试图将自己的信仰和价值观强加给当地人，但南非人很快就接受了足球并将其变成了自己的运动。
It's an interesting story whereby a colonial game really was transformed into a pillar of black culture by the racially oppressed. The game was both affordable and accessible, becoming the sport of the black working class. And when I use the term black, I'm referring to people who either are self-identified or were later classified under apartheid as African, Indian or South Asian and Colored or Multiracial. Football was not held in high regard by officials in the apartheid regime. Sports played predominantly by white South Africans like Cricket and Rugby were the ones that received political backing. So as way to help organize themselves football teams formed supporters clubs.
这是一个有趣的故事，殖民者的游戏被种族受压迫者转化为黑人文化的支柱。这项运动既负担得起又容易参与，成为了黑人工人阶级的运动。当我使用“黑人”这个词时，我指的是那些自我认同或后来在种族隔离制度下被归类为非洲人、印度人或南亚人以及有色人种或多种族的人。足球在种族隔离政权的官员眼中并不受重视。主要由白人南非人参与的运动，如板球和橄榄球，才是获得政治支持的项目。因此，为了帮助组织自己，足球队成立了球迷俱乐部。
These were small but muddy organizations made up of fans from each city or town. Supporters clubs would hold fun raises and hammer out travel logistics to away matches. And Black supporters clubs in particular played a special role, giving Black South Africans who had no say in their government a voice to shape their community through the local team. Members held elections for various positions in the supporters club, and also through their formal organization, they tried to influence the football clubs' internal affairs. And so the ability to campaign for office to achieve a kind of social honor and visibility by achieving these high offices
这些是规模虽小但充满活力的组织，由来自每个城市或城镇的球迷组成。球迷俱乐部会举行筹款活动，并商定前往客场比赛的后勤安排。特别是黑人球迷俱乐部发挥了特殊作用，让在政府中没有发言权的黑人南非人有了一个通过当地球队塑造社区的声音。成员们为球迷俱乐部的各种职位举行选举，并通过他们的正式组织，试图影响足球俱乐部的内部事务。因此，竞选公职以获得某种社会荣誉和知名度的能力，
was something that was highly valued, particularly in black communities. By the 1960s, supporter clubs existed all across South Africa and they made their presence known to the noise they generated on game days at the stadium. The crowd have flown wild. Just gravity's left to play, and it's G2, which university's two. Playing music at the grounds, chanting, singing, dancing,
在黑人社区中受到高度重视。到了20世纪60年代，球迷俱乐部遍布南非各地，他们通过在比赛日体育场内制造的噪音让人们感受到了他们的存在。人群疯狂了。只剩下几分钟了，比分是2比2。在球场上播放音乐、高呼、唱歌、跳舞，
maybe insulting the opponents, this was something intensely pleasurable and entertaining. During this time, political opponents of the apartheid regime were banned from gathering. It was one of the many ways the government tried to suppress the liberation movement, but football games and the noise and crowd that came with them made it harder to prevent black politicians from sitting together. It provided cover, in a way, by allowing activists to have conversations and even organized particular subversive activities, and in doing so, kind of undermining the white state's
也许还会侮辱对手，这是一种极其令人愉悦和娱乐的事情。在此期间，种族隔离政权的政治反对派被禁止集会。这是政府试图压制解放运动的众多方式之一，但足球比赛以及随之而来的噪音和人群，使得阻止黑人政治家坐在一起变得更加困难。它在某种程度上提供了掩护，允许活动人士进行对话，甚至组织特定的颠覆性活动，从而削弱了白人国家的监视和审查。
surveillance and censorship. The stadiums were a sort of sanctuary, a place where you could get rowdy and thumb your nose at the government, where you could fly the flag of the anti-apartheid movement while rooting for your favorite team. It was also the place where you could hear one charismatic fan pick up his horn and make a sound that would soon be heard around the world. So myself, I'm an owner, I'm a founder, I'm the pioneer of the Bupacera. It's started by me.
体育场是一种避难所，一个你可以喧闹并对政府嗤之以鼻的地方，一个你可以在为最喜欢的球队加油时挥舞反种族隔离运动旗帜的地方。这也是你可以听到一位富有魅力的球迷拿起他的喇叭，发出一种很快就会传遍世界的声音的地方。我是呜呜祖拉的所有者、创始人、先驱。它是由我开始的。
This is Freddie Marquet. They call me Mr Bupacera when I walk around. Freddie actually prefers to be called Saddam, an edgy nickname he received during the Gulf War because he used to set off huge firecrackers at football matches. People would say it sounded like the Iraq War on TV. Saddam Marke is a soccer freak or a superfan as they're known in South Africa, the most passionate football supporters. It loves the South Africa national team and his local club Kaiser
这是弗雷迪·马凯。当我走动时，他们叫我“呜呜祖拉先生”。弗雷迪实际上更喜欢被称为“萨达姆”，这是一个他在海湾战争期间得到的尖锐绰号，因为他过去常在足球比赛中燃放巨大的鞭炮。人们会说这听起来像电视上的伊拉克战争。萨达姆·马凯是一个足球狂人，或者说是南非所称的“超级球迷”，即最热情的足球支持者。他热爱南非国家队和他当地的俱乐部凯撒酋长队。
Chips from Johannesburg. He can be seen at games wearing oversized yellow glasses, a jersey and a mining helmet known as a marker wrapper, painted it in the team's colours. For Saddam, you might say football is life. My first wife divorced me because of a soccer. I said, chips is my first wife. You're my second wife. Every day, every night, when I sleep, I sleep chips.
来自约翰内斯堡。他在比赛时戴着超大的黄色眼镜，穿着球衣，戴着被称为“马卡拉帕”的矿工头盔，上面涂着球队的颜色。对于萨达姆来说，你可以说足球就是生命。我的第一任妻子因为足球和我离婚了。我说，酋长队是我的第一任妻子。你是我的第二任妻子。每天，每晚，当我睡觉时，我梦见的都是酋长队。
I sleep soccer, eat soccer, I talk soccer. I can't talk to you without talking about soka. In between all the soka chat I did manage to learn where Saddam grew up, the province of Limpoppa with his large family. His claim to the vivicella dates back to his childhood and a gift he received to his birthday in 1965. The hooter, Saddamer's referencing, is a bicycle horn.
我睡足球，吃足球，谈足球。我不谈足球就没法和你说话。在所有关于足球的聊天中，我确实了解到了萨达姆成长的地点，林波波省，以及他的大家庭。他与呜呜祖拉的渊源可以追溯到他的童年，以及他在1965年生日时收到的礼物。萨达姆提到的喇叭是一个自行车喇叭。
He'd bring that horn to local football games to support his team, but instead of squeezing the little rubber bowl with the end, he'd take that off and blow into the horn. I was doing that one to entertain the players, motivate them, encourage them to score and just say them with this one. 1965, when I arrived in Grand Speck. Saddam liked the sound that attached bicycle horn made. He called it a paulafala. When his local football club, the Kaiser Chiefs, was established in 1970, Saddam says he brought a number of other homemade horns to the game.
他会把那个喇叭带到当地的足球比赛中去支持他的球队，但他不是挤压末端的橡胶球，而是把它取下来，对着喇叭吹。我这样做是为了娱乐球员，激励他们，鼓励他们进球，并用这个声音支持他们。1965年，当我到达格兰德斯佩克时。萨达姆喜欢那个改装过的自行车喇叭发出的声音。他称之为“保拉法拉”。当他当地的足球俱乐部凯撒酋长队在1970年成立时，萨达姆说他带了许多其他自制的喇叭到比赛中。
This included a large aluminium horn, he called a burgui blast. The burgui blast was basically a long metal stick you could blow into. It was also a long metal stick you could beat someone up with, so stadiums eventually banded. But by then, in 1989, Sardam says he met with a plastic-smanu factor, and asked him to make a plastic version of the burgui blast. This new instrument they created, Sanat Simla. But it had a different name. I call it this one, Vuvuzela. Vuvuzela is derived from Zulu.
这包括一个大的铝制喇叭，他称之为“伯吉爆破器”。伯吉爆破器基本上是一根你可以吹气的长金属棍。它也是一根可以用来打人的长金属棍，所以体育场最终禁止了它。但到那时，在1989年，萨达姆说他遇到了一位塑料制造商，并要求他制作一个塑料版的伯吉爆破器。他们创造的这个新乐器，萨纳特·西姆拉。但它有一个不同的名字。我叫它这个，呜呜祖拉。呜呜祖拉源自祖鲁语。
Vuvuzela means welcome and unite. Same thing, Vuvuzela, welcome and unite. Saddam says he coined the name Vuvuzela back in 1992, a claim he supports, with photos of him blowing his many horns at football games in the 70s and 80s and a Vuvuzela in the 90s. He also recorded an album in 1999 titled Vuvuzela Cellula. So now I'm trying to sell some of these plastic horns at football matches, but it just never really gained traction. Even at cars of Chafes games, it would often be one of the only supporters in the crowd, blowing a vuvuzella. However, that slowly started to change when a company in Cape Town started mass producing
呜呜祖拉意味着欢迎和团结。同样的事情，呜呜祖拉，欢迎和团结。萨达姆说他在1992年创造了“呜呜祖拉”这个名字，他用他在70年代和80年代在足球比赛中吹奏他的许多喇叭以及90年代吹奏呜呜祖拉的照片来支持这一说法。他还在1999年录制了一张名为《呜呜祖拉·塞卢拉》的专辑。所以现在我试着在足球比赛中卖一些这种塑料喇叭，但它从来没有真正流行起来。即使在酋长队的比赛中，他通常也是人群中唯一一个吹呜呜祖拉的支持者。然而，当开普敦的一家公司开始大规模生产时，这种情况开始慢慢改变。
their own plastic warrants, which they also called the vuvuzella. The company's name is Massin Fedani Sports. The click is important because the name of the company is from Iskosa. This is Duane Jethro. He studies South African culture and wrote about the history of the vivisower. Duane says that back in 2001, Neil Vanskogvik and his partner, Bevel Bachmann, got funding to get their business off the ground. He pitched this idea of injection molding a horn to a certain size and a certain specification
他们自己的塑料喇叭，他们也称之为呜呜祖拉。这家公司的名字是Massin Fedani Sports。点击很重要，因为公司的名字来自科萨语。这是杜安·杰斯罗。他研究南非文化，并撰写了关于呜呜祖拉历史的文章。杜安说，早在2001年，尼尔·范·斯考尔维克和他的合伙人贝弗尔·巴赫曼获得了资金来启动他们的业务。他提出了将喇叭注塑成一定尺寸和规格的想法，
that would be easily used at foot pro matches. Around the same time this new company was getting started Saddam Make says he approached Neil van Skolkvik to tell him that he was the true inventor of the vuvuzella. Saddam says he tried to strike a business deal. Did you ever speak with Neil? Neil Van... Yes, I speak to you. I speak to you and he promised me, each move is Ella. I'm going to get a fight right out of each move is Ella. And I never get even a cent, but I didn't worry. I didn't complain, I said to myself, God is great.
这将很容易在足球比赛中使用。大约在同一时间，这家新公司开始起步，萨达姆·马凯说他找到尼尔·范·斯考尔维克，告诉他他是呜呜祖拉的真正发明者。萨达姆说他试图达成一笔商业交易。你和尼尔谈过吗？尼尔·范……是的，我和他谈过。我和他谈过，他向我承诺，每一个呜呜祖拉。我会从每一个呜呜祖拉中得到一份。但我连一分钱都没拿到，但我并不担心。我没有抱怨，我对自己说，上帝是伟大的。
We tried to track Neil Van's Skulkvik down for an interview, but run successful. According to media reports, he denied ever meeting with Saddam Makhay in 2001. In interviews, Van Skullcvik didn't claim to be the inventor of the Vibuzella, but he and his company assert that they did popularize it. Their version of the horn was cheaper and safer, and that you couldn't beat someone up with one. Actually, Raymond, you technically could beat someone up with it. Right. It wouldn't hurt as bad.
我们试图追踪尼尔·范·斯考尔维克进行采访，但没有成功。据媒体报道，他否认在2001年与萨达姆·马凯见过面。在采访中，范·斯考尔维克并没有声称自己是呜呜祖拉的发明者，但他和他的公司断言他们确实推广了它。他们的喇叭版本更便宜、更安全，而且你不能用它打人。其实，雷蒙德，从技术上讲，你还是可以用它打人的。对。只是不会那么疼。
Well, look, you know, we were at the forefront of developing the first plastic version of a turn-horn that used to be used in, you know, football, the Ainsard Africa. And because, you know, those horns were quite unsafe at the time, we saw the gap in the market to produce a plastic version of that one. Initially, Vince Goldfix Company also struggled to sell their Vuvozele's, but that changed when they started to focus on the marketing. The company had that Vuvozele's for free at football matches and partnered with some local clubs to get more of them into South Africa's stadiums.
嗯，你看，你知道，我们处于开发第一款塑料版喇叭的最前沿，这种喇叭过去常用于南非的足球比赛。而且因为，你知道，那些喇叭在当时很不安全，我们看到了市场上的空白，生产了一个塑料版本。最初，范·斯考尔维克的公司也难以销售他们的呜呜祖拉，但当他们开始专注于营销时，情况发生了变化。该公司在足球比赛中免费赠送呜呜祖拉，并与一些当地俱乐部合作，将更多的呜呜祖拉带入南非的体育场。
It wasn't long before there was more interest in the Vuvuzella and sales started to grow. Soon, the instrument could be distinctly heard at games across the country. about to get on a waste and on the fabrics on the floor and just their macabre. So that's the change and chiefs it made. The Vuvuzella effectively being Agent Eric Horn meant that Vince Gulkvik wasn't able to patent the design. But the word Vuvuzella was unique, so his company got a trademark for the name. And as South Africa prepared, they bid to host the 2010 World Cup. Vince Gulkvik and his company were ready to capitalize on the event. the 2010 World Cup, fans Goldwick and his company were rated to capitalize on the event. The company's efforts were designed to position the vivisower as authentic, including its official slogan, the original sound of South Africa.
没过多久，人们对呜呜祖拉的兴趣就增加了，销量也开始增长。很快，这种乐器在全国各地的比赛中都能清晰地听到。呜呜祖拉实际上是一种通用的喇叭，这意味着范·斯考尔维克无法为该设计申请专利。但“呜呜祖拉”这个词是独一无二的，所以他的公司为这个名字注册了商标。随着南非准备申办2010年世界杯，范·斯考尔维克和他的公司准备利用这一赛事。公司的努力旨在将呜呜祖拉定位为正宗的，包括其官方口号，“南非的原始声音”。
They recognized that there was a marketing opportunity in having the vuvuzella in the hands of important South African footballing officials, but also politicians that were trying to drum up support both locally and internationally for South Africa's. So what you saw was things like the gifting of vuvuzelas as diplomatic gifts on local stages, politicians were handed, vuvuzelas, etc. When FIFA announced South Africa's winning bid to host the tournament, the joyful celebrations included these plastic vuvuzillas. The aggressive marketing worked, and the lead up to the World Cup, the sound of South African football was inextricably linked to the vuvuzella.
他们认识到，让重要的南非足球官员以及试图在当地和国际上为南非申办世界杯争取支持的政治家手中持有呜呜祖拉是一个营销机会。所以你看到的是像在当地舞台上赠送呜呜祖拉作为外交礼物，政治家被递给呜呜祖拉等。当国际足联宣布南非赢得世界杯主办权时，欢乐的庆祝活动中就包括了这些塑料呜呜祖拉。激进的营销奏效了，在世界杯前夕，南非足球的声音与呜呜祖拉密不可分。
The instrument even appeared in national marketing campaigns, fronted by prominent rugby players who'd been called in to promote the 2009 Confederations Cup, a sort of test run tournament for the World Cup. The Confederations Cup was the first time a global TV audience had been exposed to the Vuvazela. Not long after the first game, the international debate started taking off. One thing that I found, I don't know if I'm the only person I found excruciating was this constant droning. Oh yeah. It was going on. They're growing. These are trumpet looking I don't know how they have enough air in their lungs and it never ends. Yeah. And it is
这种乐器甚至出现在全国性的营销活动中，由著名的橄榄球运动员带头，他们被召集来推广2009年联合会杯，这是一种世界杯的测试赛。联合会杯是全球电视观众第一次接触到呜呜祖拉。第一场比赛后不久，国际辩论就开始了。我发现的一件事，我不知道我是不是唯一一个觉得极其痛苦的人，就是这种持续不断的嗡嗡声。哦，是的。它一直在持续。它们在嗡嗡作响。这些看起来像小号的东西，我不知道他们的肺里怎么有足够的空气，而且它永远不会结束。是的。而且它
just a, it is like you are, you are being attacked by a swarm of locusts for 90 consecutive minutes. I know exactly what you're talking about. How can they constantly do that? I don't know. I don't know if they take turns, but it is. Media reports were quick to raise concerns about the Vuvuzela's potential impact on the World Cup.
就像你，你被一群蝗虫攻击了整整90分钟。我知道你在说什么。他们怎么能一直那样做？我不知道。我不知道他们是否轮流，但确实如此。媒体报道很快就对呜呜祖拉对世界杯的潜在影响提出了担忧。
Set Blatter, the beloved and totally non-controversial FIFA president, was asked if the Viva Zalla was going to be banned at the upcoming World Cup. To the surprise of many, he came out in support of the instrument, saying it is African culture. We are in Africa, and we have to allow them to practice their culture as much as they want to. He's journalist Mark Gleason again. It struck me at that point that that was the turning moment because I do think it was a bit of an issue for FIFA, whether the Vuvuzela was going to be part of the 2010 World Cup or not.
塞普·布拉特，那位深受爱戴且完全没有争议的国际足联主席，被问及呜呜祖拉是否会在即将到来的世界杯上被禁止。令许多人惊讶的是，他站出来支持这种乐器，称这是非洲文化。我们在非洲，我们必须允许他们尽可能多地实践他们的文化。他又是记者马克·格里森。那一刻让我印象深刻，因为我认为这对国际足联来说确实是一个问题，呜呜祖拉是否会成为2010年世界杯的一部分。
It's a moment I remember very distinctly and thinking to myself, this is the Vuvuzela now. We will have the Vuvuzela in 2010. From the moment the World Cup kicked off, the Wu-Wu Zelda was a constant and persistent presence. From the atmosphere and the stadiums to the jokes on late-night TV, it was inescapable. While broadcasters were trying to mitigate the noise on their end, DIY solutions were making their way around the internet. One of them involved writing your TV's audio through your computer and using software to
这是一个我记得非常清楚的时刻，我对自己说，这就是现在的呜呜祖拉。我们将在2010年拥有呜呜祖拉。从世界杯开赛的那一刻起，呜呜祖拉就是一个持续且顽固的存在。从体育场的气氛到深夜电视节目上的笑话，它无处不在。当广播公司试图在他们那边减轻噪音时，DIY解决方案正在互联网上传播。其中之一涉及将电视的音频通过电脑，并使用软件来
remove the particular frequencies of the Vivicella. And as the tournament continued, players on the field cited the Vivicella for causing communication problems. Lino Messi, regarded by many as the best player in the world, even went so far as to blame the noise for his team conceding a goal. The complaints were even enough to inspire a study from the South African medical journal. It measured the vivicella's sound levels, which peaked at 131 decibels. That's as loud as a jackhammer or a jet engine.
去除呜呜祖拉的特定频率。随着锦标赛的继续，场上的球员指责呜呜祖拉造成了沟通问题。莱昂内尔·梅西，被许多人认为是世界上最好的球员，甚至把噪音归咎于他的球队丢球。这些投诉甚至足以激发《南非医学杂志》的一项研究。它测量了呜呜祖拉的声级，峰值达到131分贝。这和手提钻或喷气发动机一样响。
It concluded that prolonged or regular exposure could cause noise-induced hearing loss. There was no middle ground with the vivicella. You either loved it or hated it. Most of the Vuvozala outrage came from a very Eurocentric perspective. It was an argument about what was considered appropriate in football fan culture, which Duane Jethroy says was an attack on the idea of African-ness. It raises old, old ideas of Africa's dark continent, cultural forms from Africa as being primitive or outdated, etc. And I think that's how the outrage was received in South Africa. And it was in that space that not only the South African Football Association,
结论是，长期或经常接触可能会导致噪音引起的听力损失。呜呜祖拉没有中间地带。你要么爱它，要么恨它。大多数对呜呜祖拉的愤怒来自一种非常欧洲中心主义的视角。这是一个关于足球球迷文化中什么是适当的争论，杜安·杰斯罗说这是对非洲性观念的攻击。它引发了关于非洲作为黑暗大陆的古老观念，来自非洲的文化形式被认为是原始或过时的等等。我认为这就是愤怒在南非被接收的方式。正是在那个空间里，不仅是南非足球协会，
but also South African fans started to speak back and speak out and to say that this is how we represent ourselves in our sporting traditions and sporting fan culture. While the Vivi Zoa was condemned by international audiences, it's also true that many visitors to South Africa embraced it. For comedian Trevor Noah and plenty of other South Africans, the appropriation was the problem. In South Africa, we should have a thing where you have to have a license to blow a Vousela.
而且南非球迷也开始反击并大声疾呼，说这就是我们在体育传统和体育球迷文化中代表自己的方式。虽然呜呜祖拉受到国际观众的谴责，但许多南非游客也确实接受了它。对于喜剧演员特雷弗·诺亚和许多其他南非人来说，挪用才是问题所在。在南非，我们应该有一个规定，你必须有执照才能吹呜呜祖拉。
You can't just come here, not knowing voo-vousela etiquette, blowing it randomly. The English fans, the Spanish fans should be blowing the vizelas. There's no doubt that for thousands of South Africans, the vuvuzella was an expression of national identity. But as the first African nation to host the World Cup, the instrument came to represent more than just South Africa. For viewers watching around the world, it represented the sound of an entire continent. That was by design. FIFA and South Africa's organizing committee marketed the tournament as Africa's World Cup.
你不能只是来到这里，不知道呜呜祖拉的礼仪，随意吹奏。英国球迷、西班牙球迷不应该吹呜呜祖拉。毫无疑问，对于成千上万的南非人来说，呜呜祖拉是民族认同的表达。但作为第一个举办世界杯的非洲国家，这种乐器代表的不仅仅是南非。对于全世界的观众来说，它代表了整个非洲大陆的声音。这是有意为之的。国际足联和南非组委会将锦标赛营销为“非洲的世界杯”。
The slogan was, celebrate Africa's humanity. Even the official song of the tournament, which you'll surely remember, proclaims this time is for Africa. And because the Vivicella became such a huge focal point of the event, Petyr Lege says the instrument got wrapped up in all the arcanography of the tournament, too. The government was keen on using it because it's side as a symbol of, you know, African-ness. But there are also other African visitors who hated it, who said, you know, we have no tradition of horn blowing where I come from.
口号是，“庆祝非洲的人性”。即使是锦标赛的官方歌曲，你肯定记得，也宣称“这一刻属于非洲”。而且因为呜呜祖拉成为了赛事的一个巨大焦点，彼得·阿莱吉说这种乐器也被卷入了锦标赛的所有图像中。政府热衷于使用它，因为它被视为一种非洲性的象征。但也有其他非洲游客讨厌它，他们说，你知道，我来自的地方没有吹喇叭的传统。
So how is this supposed to represent pan-Africanism? The disneyification of the tournament made the Vizella fill cheap, like the rest of the marketing around it. And with that cheapness, came a certain skepticism about its authenticity. Despite the instrument being so criticized, people still wanted to claim credit for its existence. The disputes over its history and origin played out side by side with the tournament. One story the press picked up connected the vivicella to the horn of the kudu, a species
那么这怎么能代表泛非主义呢？锦标赛的迪士尼化让呜呜祖拉感觉很廉价，就像它周围的其他营销一样。随着这种廉价感，人们对它的真实性产生了一定的怀疑。尽管这种乐器受到如此多的批评，但人们仍然想为它的存在争取功劳。关于其历史和起源的争议与锦标赛并存。媒体报道的一个故事将呜呜祖拉与库杜的角联系起来，这是一种羚羊。
of antelope. Historicly, animal horns have been used in South African culture, but the theory linking the kudo horn to the vivazewa was likely inspired by one supporter of the team Mamolody Sundowns, who was known to bring the horn to football games. He is researcher Dwayne Jethro again. While it is absolutely true that we have indigenous traditions of horn blowing in South Africa, whether and how we can trace a genealogy of the vuvuzela all the way back to those indigenous traditions, that's open to argument and debate.
历史上，动物角在南非文化中一直被使用，但将库杜角与呜呜祖拉联系起来的理论很可能是受到马梅洛迪日落队的一位支持者的启发，他以带角去足球比赛而闻名。他又是研究员杜安·杰斯罗。虽然我们在南非确实有土著吹喇叭的传统是绝对正确的，但我们是否以及如何能将呜呜祖拉的谱系追溯到那些土著传统，这是有争议和辩论的。
Another claim came from the Nazareth Baptist Church, also known as the Shembae, who have a horn of their own. The Shembae Church operates in the Kuzalunatal area. They have an annual pilgrimage and during this annual pilgrimage they use a horn called the Izibomu. When football fans were blowing the fulfusela they felt that the Holy spudded was generated
另一个说法来自拿撒勒浸信会，也被称为“谢姆贝”，他们有自己的喇叭。谢姆贝教会在夸祖鲁-纳塔尔地区运作。他们每年都有朝圣活动，在这次年度朝圣期间，他们使用一种叫做“伊齐博穆”的喇叭。当足球迷吹奏呜呜祖拉时，他们觉得那种神圣的氛围被
by their own had been appropriated in this context of a football atmosphere. The Shembe first accused Saddam Maki of appropriating the Isambomu. They said he visited the church in the 90s and fashioned his own version in plastic when he wasn't allowed to bring the metal horn into stadiums. Saddam denies these accusations. The church threatened the legal action initially against FIFA and World Cup organizers before going after Neil van Skolkvik and his company. According to media reports at the time, the two parties eventually came to a settlement. All these claims regarding the origin of the Fuvuzella are compelling in their own way,
他们自己的喇叭所产生，却在足球氛围的背景下被挪用了。谢姆贝人首先指责萨达姆·马凯挪用了伊齐博穆。他们说他在90年代访问了教堂，并在他不被允许将金属喇叭带入体育场时，用塑料制作了自己的版本。萨达姆否认了这些指控。教会在起诉尼尔·范·斯考尔维克和他的公司之前，最初威胁要对国际足联和世界杯组织者采取法律行动。据当时的媒体报道，双方最终达成了和解。所有关于呜呜祖拉起源的说法都有其吸引力，
but it was the heightened context of the World Cup tournament that raised the stakes in the ownership debate. In all cultural heritage debates, origins and ownership are really important elements and strands of being able to claim a certain heritage tradition. You cannot claim a heritage tradition until you can claim ownership and a valid persuasive origin story. Despite the lack of a straightforward origin story, the vivazella is still considered cultural heritage, at least in the eyes of some institutions. The United Kingdom's National Football Museum and the British Museum both have vizellas
但正是世界杯锦标赛的高调背景提高了所有权辩论的赌注。在所有文化遗产辩论中，起源和所有权是能够声称某种遗产传统的重要元素和主线。在你能够声称所有权和有效且有说服力的起源故事之前，你不能声称某种遗产传统。尽管缺乏直接的起源故事，但呜呜祖拉仍然被认为是文化遗产，至少在一些机构眼中是这样。英国国家足球博物馆和大英博物馆都有呜呜祖拉
in their collections. So if we use the collecting principles of these heritage institutions as a guideline for how heritage is staked and made, then you see the vovuzella entering into that heritage narrative. I mean, the British Museum is no stranger to stealing credit for cultural artifacts. But if you look up the Vivicella's listing on their website, there is only one origin
在他们的收藏中。所以，如果我们使用这些遗产机构的收藏原则作为遗产如何被界定和制造的指南，那么你就会看到呜呜祖拉进入了那个遗产叙事。我的意思是，大英博物馆对窃取文化文物的功劳并不陌生。但如果你在他们的网站上查找呜呜祖拉的列表，只有一个起源
story they recognize. For me to talk about this Wusella, you make my day. I attribute the invention to none other than Freddie Saddam Marquet. Saddam's story is the closest thing the Vivazela has to an actual origin story. And unlike the noise that surrounded the Vivazela in 2010, his story at its core is simple. He loved his team and he wanted to show his support for them as loud as possible. Today, we Vizela's aren't nearly as prominent as they were back in 2010. A few years after the South African World Cup ended, FIFA turned around and banned them
故事是他们认可的。对我来说，谈论这个呜呜祖拉，你让我的一天变得美好。我将发明归功于弗雷迪·萨达姆·马凯本人。萨达姆的故事是呜呜祖拉最接近实际起源故事的东西。而且与2010年围绕呜呜祖拉的噪音不同，他的故事核心很简单。他热爱他的球队，他想尽可能大声地表达他的支持。今天，呜呜祖拉不像2010年那样突出了。南非世界杯结束后几年，国际足联转而禁止了它们
from all major tournaments, and several other major sports leagues have as well. But for Dwayne Jethro, that comes with his overlining. I'm very glad that no future World Cup tournament will be blessed with a beautiful sound of the Vuvuzella, that the sound will always remain South African. Just a few months ago, the South African women's football team won their first ever Africa Cup of Nations. When the team arrived at the airport, they were greeted by fans expressing their national pride through songs and chants. Saddam Marquet was there too, blowing his Vivizzella.
参加所有重大锦标赛，其他几个主要体育联盟也一样。但对于杜安·杰斯罗来说，这有其阴暗面。我很高兴未来的世界杯锦标赛不会再有呜呜祖拉的美妙声音，这种声音将永远保持南非特色。就在几个月前，南非女子足球队赢得了她们有史以来的第一个非洲国家杯。当球队到达机场时，她们受到了球迷的欢迎，球迷们通过歌曲和口号表达了她们的民族自豪感。萨达姆·马凯也在那里，吹着他的呜呜祖拉。
They were no complaints about the noise. The fans just celebrated the way they wanted to celebrate. So I'm back with James Parkinson and you've got another story about football culture in South Africa for us. Yes, so if you have interesting details, came up while I was working on this story and it has to do with that culture of noise making in the stadiums and I'm dropping you a picture now so you can see what I'm talking about. So this must be Saddam Make who we we heard from in the piece, who has a really great voice and a really great look to go with it. Yes, this is Saddam of Vivice Alaphayne. And in this picture,
没有人抱怨噪音。球迷们只是以他们想要的方式庆祝。所以我又和詹姆斯·帕金森在一起了，你为我们准备了另一个关于南非足球文化的故事。是的，所以如果有一些有趣的细节，在我做这个故事时出现了，它与体育场内的噪音制造文化有关，我现在给你发一张照片，这样你就能看到我在说什么。所以这一定是我们在节目中听到的萨达姆·马凯，他有一个非常棒的声音和非常棒的外表。是的，这就是呜呜祖拉之王萨达姆。在这张照片里，
he's decked out in all this gear, screaming his lungs out at a football match. He's wearing really large, comically yellow glasses and a helmet with all the different logos on it and AC stickers of Kaiser Chiefs and even Orlando Pirates on it. Yes, so what I want to talk about is that helmet, the Macarapa, because that was another item like the Vizella that gained popularity during the World Cup.
他穿着所有的装备，在足球比赛中声嘶力竭地尖叫。他戴着非常大、滑稽的黄色眼镜，戴着一个上面有各种不同标志的头盔，上面贴着凯撒酋长队甚至奥兰多海盗队的贴纸。是的，所以我想谈谈那个头盔，马卡拉帕，因为那是另一件像呜呜祖拉一样在世界杯期间流行起来的物品。
So the word Macarapa actually means scrapers. And scrapers is a reference to the migrant workers. He used to move into cities like Johannesburg to work in the mines. People would say they scrape for a living. And so the story goes that Kaiser Chiefs fan, not Saddam this time, went to a particularly rarity game back in the 70s, where he saw someone
所以“马卡拉帕”这个词实际上意味着“刮削者”。而刮削者是指那些搬到约翰内斯堡等城市在矿井工作的外来务工人员。人们会说他们靠刮削为生。所以故事是这样的，凯撒酋长队的球迷，这次不是萨达姆，在70年代去了一场特别喧闹的比赛，在那里他看到有人
get hit in the head with a bottle. So naturally for the next game, he thought, you know, I'd just... I was like, well, I should wear that helmet. Yeah, exactly. All these people wearing helmets, I should wear helmet. Yeah. So this fan started painting these helmets in the Tim's colors and selling them at
头部被瓶子击中。所以很自然地，在下一场比赛中，他想，你知道，我只是……我想，嗯，我应该戴那个头盔。是的，完全正确。所有这些人戴着头盔，我也应该戴头盔。是的。所以这个球迷开始把这些头盔涂上球队的颜色并在
games and it became a thing. But this isn't the only connection between the minds of South Africa and noise making in the stadiums. Do I, and Jethro told me there's also this sound. It's a kind of alarm. It's a kind of alarm, it's a wind up alarm, it goes, ooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo the games, and they're pretty popular in the 90s. Yeah. Because these are working class fans, so they're bringing what they have on them. They're bringing their helmets, they're bringing their sirens that they use in everyday
比赛中出售，它就成了一件事。但这并不是南非矿井与体育场内制造噪音之间的唯一联系。杜安·杰斯罗告诉我还有这种声音。这是一种警报。这是一种警报，它是一个发条警报，它发出“呜呜呜”的声音，在比赛中，它们在90年代非常流行。是的。因为这些是工人阶级的球迷，所以他们带来了他们身上有的东西。他们带来了他们的头盔，他们带来了他们在日常生活中使用的警报器
life. Yeah, they'll picking up their helmets and, you know, these alarms and sort of repurposing them to reflect their lives as miners in the culture of South African football. Oh, I love that. I love that. Yeah, and one of my favorite examples of this is that they repurbished a work song they would sing in the minds that fans would then sing, you know,
生活。是的，他们会拿起他们的头盔，你知道，这些警报器，并以某种方式重新利用它们，以反映他们作为矿工在南非足球文化中的生活。哦，我喜欢那个。我喜欢那个。是的，我最喜欢的例子之一是他们重新利用了他们在矿井里唱的一首劳动歌曲，球迷们随后会唱，你知道，
Lately, it games and it's called Shoshu Loza. And you sing it, it goes something like Shosholoza, Muzhez, Uta-Bast, Tumela, Sumela, Deh-ma-le, na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na you sing when you really want to arouse up the crowd and South Africans across the board know the song. And it speaks to migrants moving from different parts of Southern Africa to come and work on their minds. So, Joshua Walser, this traditional minor song
在比赛中，它叫《Shosholoza》。你唱它，它听起来像这样……当你真的想激起人群时，你会唱它，南非各地的南非人都知道这首歌。它讲述了移民从南部非洲的不同地区搬来在矿井工作的故事。所以，《Shosholoza》，这首传统的矿工歌曲
actually became quite popular in the 90s. People refer to it as South Africa's second national anthem. It was sung in a call and response style by the workers to kind of generate a rhythm and also to alleviate stress from working long hard days underground. Shoshalwaza means go forward or make the way for the next man. And famously Nelson Mandela spoke about how he would sing this song while he was in prisons on Robin Ireland off the coast of Cape Town, along with, you know, many political prisoners, and the ways in which the song reflected
实际上在90年代变得非常流行。人们称它为南非的第二国歌。它由工人们以呼应的方式演唱，以产生一种节奏，也为了缓解在地下长时间艰苦工作带来的压力。《Shosholoza》意味着“前进”或“为下一个人开路”。纳尔逊·曼德拉曾著名地谈到他在开普敦海岸外的罗本岛监狱服刑时，是如何与许多政治犯一起唱这首歌的，以及这首歌如何反映了
the struggle during apartheid. Hmm, I mean, it reminds me of something that you mentioned in the piece that these games and the noise that surrounds them. I mean, yes, it's about sports and a game and about leisure and fun, but it's also like a certain amount of political resistance just built into the fact that there's people singing along loudly in a stadium,
种族隔离期间的斗争。嗯，我的意思是，这让我想起了你在节目中提到的，这些比赛和围绕它们的噪音。我的意思是，是的，这是关于体育、游戏、休闲和娱乐，但它也像是一种政治抵抗，内置在体育场里人们大声跟唱的事实中，
they're playing instruments, and this is way to make noise for your team, but also, you know, let the powers of B know that, you know, we're all here, and there's a bunch of us, and we're all here. Yeah, we're here, let you know. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by James Parkinson, edited by Jason D'Alione, sound mixed by Martin Gonzales, music bar director of sound, Swan Rio. With additional music provided by Freddie Saddam Make, fact checking by Graham Haysha, Delini Hall is our senior editor at Kirk Coleset is the digital director. Levy Green is our intern. The resident includes Vivian Leigh, Loshamadon, Chris Barouba, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher
他们演奏乐器，这是一种为你的球队制造噪音的方式，但也，你知道，让当权者知道，你知道，我们都在这里，我们有一大群人，我们都在这里。是的，我们在这里，让你知道。《99%隐形》本周由詹姆斯·帕金森制作，杰森·达利奥内编辑，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，音乐总监斯旺·里奥。弗雷迪·萨达姆·马凯提供了额外的音乐，格雷厄姆·海沙进行了事实核查，德利尼·霍尔是我们的高级编辑，柯克·科尔塞特是数字总监。利维·格林是我们的实习生。常驻人员包括薇薇安·李、洛沙马顿、克里斯·巴鲁巴、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗
Johnson, Jacob Multanada Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klassker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to Dwayne Jathro, he's the author of Heritage, Formation, and the Census and Post-Apartade South Africa, which includes a chapter called Vuvuzela Magic. Peter Allegi is also the author of several books, including LaDouma Soccer, Politics and Society in South Africa, and thanks to Peter Druie, who we also spoke with for the story. We are part of the Citrus and Sirius XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building.
约翰逊、雅各布·穆尔塔纳达·梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉斯克，还有我罗曼·马尔斯。特别感谢杜安·杰斯罗，他是《后种族隔离时代南非的遗产、形成和普查》的作者，其中包括一章名为《呜呜祖拉魔法》。彼得·阿莱吉也是几本书的作者，包括《LaDouma足球、政治与南非社会》，感谢彼得·德鲁伊，我们也和他谈过这个故事。我们是Citrus和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大楼。
And beautiful. Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 999 PI orc. Well on Instagram, read it and now tick-tock too. You can find links to other stitch art shows I love,
在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。在Instagram、Reddit和现在的TikTok上也可以。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，
as well as every past episode of 99PO at 99p P.O.D. Say, be my child, come on you, you're too much, oh, when my child, say, do not you dare, say, be my child, There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及《99%隐形》的每一集往期节目，网址是99p.org。说，做我的孩子，来吧，你太过分了，哦，当我的孩子，说，你敢，说，做我的孩子，这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。